formationen für alle diejenigen die uns
heute live im fernsehen verfolgen dies
ist eine veranstaltung der
bundespressekonferenz die
bundespressekonferenz ist ein verein
regierungsunabhängiger als an
regierungsunabhängige verein in dem
journalistinnen und journalisten
zusammen geschlossen sind die über die
bundesregierung und über den bundestag
berichten und wir gewährleisten dass
unsere mitglieder also die
hauptstadtjournalisten und auch die
mitglieder des vereins der
auslandspresse also alle ausländischen
kollegen die über deutschland von hier
aus berichten hier fragen stellen können
und auch zu wort kommen
wir freuen uns immer dass die gäste zu
uns kommen heute der ethikrat sonst die
mitglieder der regierung oder die
sprecher der regierung und in besonderen
zeiten wie diesen machen wir eine
live-übertragung der pressekonferenzen
möglich und herzlichen dank an phoenix
die uns unterstützen mit einer
gebärdendolmetscherin und einem
gebärdendolmetscher und jetzt hat herr
professor dabrock das wort bitte schön
ja vielen dank frau wefers sehr geehrte
damen und herren
vielen dank der bundespressekonferenz
dass sie dem ethikrat die gelegenheit
gibt seine position zur krone krise zu
erläutern
ein kollege der verfassungsrechtler
stephan haux berg der diese
stellungnahme wesentlich mit verfasst
hat und ich peter dabrock der
vorsitzende des deutschen ethikrates
werden dies tun zu sagen die korona
krise hat uns im griff hat ungefähr
einen solchen nachrichtenwert hier an
einem regentag darauf hinzuweisen dass
es regnet aber seitdem der deutsche
ethikrat von neun tagen seine
stellungnahme solidarität und
verantwortung in der korona krise
veröffentlicht hat hat sich die
diskussion um die zwei von uns
behandelten themenfelder intensiviert
das sind die debatten um die triage also
die tragischen entscheidungen bei
knappheit intensivmedizinischer
kapazitäten und um die lockerung der
derzeitigen freiheitsbeschränkungen von
uns
unter dem stichwort öffnungs
perspektiven geführt die zu beobachtende
intensivierung der diskussion beruf
natürlich zuvorderst auf der
weiterentwicklung der pandemie für ein
gremium dessen gesetzliche aufgabe darin
besteht bundestag und bundesregierung zu
beraten aber auch öffentliche diskurse
zu stimulieren ist das anhalten der
durchaus kontroversen debatte
selbstverständlich kein grund zur sorge
die debatte kann und sollte von allen
auch von der politik als ausdruck der
offenen gesellschaft begrüßt werden
denn wenn menschen schon in einem
bewundernswerten maße solidarität zeigen
und teils sehr drastische freiheits
einschränkungen recht klaglos in kauf
nehmen
dann darf man ihn nicht das recht
absprechen über die unbekannten
herausforderungen der gegenwart
nachzudenken ja auch zu klagen darauf
hinzuweisen was sie bei sich und bei
anderen an belastungen erleben oder zu
hinterfragen ob die ergriffenen
maßnahmen verhältnismäßig sind
es ist vor diesem hintergrund nicht nur
legitim sondern geboten sich auch
gedanken zu machen wie es weitergeht und
unter welchen bedingungen öffnungs
perspektiven verantwortbar ja vielleicht
sogar geboten sind die korona krise ist
die stunde der demokratisch
legitimierten politik mit diesem satz
schließen wir unsere stellungnahme
verstanden als einladung und
aufforderung dass die entschlossenheit
der handelnden politik gestärkt wird
wenn sie je länger je mehr den
resonanzraum der öffentlichkeit sucht
den bürgerinnen und bürgern die diese
öffentlichkeit sind muss ihrerseits eine
gewisse geduld abverlangt werden weil
wir den höhe
der krise offensichtlich noch vor uns
haben
es ist zu früh öffnungen jetzt
vorzunehmen
aber es ist nie zu früh über kriterien
für öffnungen nachzudenken
alles andere wäre ein
obrigkeitsstaatliches denken dass bei
uns nicht verfangen sollte und mit dem
man das so notwendige vertrauen der
bevölkerung nicht stärken würde
umgekehrt gilt eine politik die in
dieser krise entschlossene verantwortung
zeigt und zeigen muss braucht das
vertrauen der bevölkerung
bevor wir ihnen rede und antwort stehen
wie wir die stellungnahme des ethikrates
zu den möglichen tragischen
entscheidungen in kliniken und zu den
öffnungszeiten des gegenwärtig
gesellschaftlichen stillstandes vor dem
hintergrund der letzten tage aktuell
verstehen möchte mein kollege steffen
augsburg und ich ihnen kurz die
wesentlichen empfehlungen in erinnerung
rufen
steffen augsburg erläutert die
empfehlungen zur so genannten träger
situation
ich möchte danach über die kriterien für
öffnungs perspektiven des gegenwärtigen
lockdown benennen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
auch von meiner seite aus ein herzliches
willkommen und ganz herzlichen dank dass
sie uns bei diesem wichtigen thema ihre
aufmerksamkeit schenken
das stichwort triage war wahrscheinlich
bis vor wenigen wochen jedenfalls in der
weiteren bevölkerung außerhalb der
kreise vielleicht von medizinethikern
und juristen weitgehend unbekannt heute
kennen es alle und viele haben
berechtigte sorgen worum geht es der
begriff umschreibt die wahrscheinlich
dramatisch so jedenfalls die am
unmittelbarsten erlebbare und in den
nachbarländern ja leider
auch bereits erlebte herausforderung
dieser aktuellen krise in situationen
echter knappheit hier geht es vor allen
dingen um beatmungs plätze ist die
verteilungs entscheidung im wortsinne
existenziell
mit dieser entscheidung wird bestimmt
wer leben darf und wer sterben muss
grundlegender und schwieriger können
ethische und rechtliche fragen kaum sein
in solchen tatsächlich tragischen
situationen gibt es dementsprechend auch
keine gute sondern allenfalls eine
vorzugswürdige entscheidung nach welchen
kriterien diese getroffen wird folgt
auch aus dem zugrunde gelegten
verhältnis von recht und ethik
man kann einerseits ethik unabhängig vom
recht als alternative und gegebenenfalls
kontrapunkt zu diesem denken
vorzugswürdig erscheint uns andererseits
hingegen ein ethik verständnis dass das
geltende recht als ausdruck
demokratischer selbstbestimmung
konsequent mit reflektiert und zumindest
als referenzpunkt akzeptiert vor diesem
hintergrund geht der deutsche ethikrat
das komplexe problem der triage in einem
dreifach gestuften vorgehen an
in einem ersten schritt identifizieren
wir elementare auch in der krise nicht
auf die bahre grund vorgaben des
verfassungsrechts zu diesen zählt
zunächst und zuvörderst die aus der
menschenwürde abgeleitet die egalitäre
basis gleichheit aller menschen diese
wieder streitet nicht nur spezifischen
diskriminierungs handlung sie verbietet
es dem staat auch qualitative oder
quantitative kriterien an das
menschliche leben anzulegen jeder mensch
ist gleich viel wert
im zweiten schritt wird dann von uns
gefragt wie sich diese basalen rechts
normativen vorgaben nutzer möglichkeit
nicht rechtlicher konkretisierung etwa
in form von empfehlungen von
fachgesellschaften verhalten
die antwort darauf ist zweigeteilt
erstens halten wir solche nicht
rechtlichen vorgaben für hilfreich mit
blick auf gleichbehandlungs ansprüche
letztlich sogar für geboten
moralische einschätzung sind aber nicht
fern vom recht zu denken sie haben sich
an die rechtlichen vorgaben zu halten
deshalb mögen sie uns zwar eine
abweichende den rechtlichen vorgaben
jedenfalls teilweise widersprechende
einschätzung nahelegen etwa den viel
gesprochenen schutz der jüngeren
gegenüber der älteren person das führt
allerdings nicht zur rechtmäßigkeit
solcher entscheidungen
der dritte schritt besteht nun darin
diese perspektive die er zunächst auf
die objektive seite ausgerichtet ist in
einer gewissen drehung und weiterführung
auf die individuelle verantwortung hin
zu konkretisieren
das verweist primär auf die
strafrechtliche handhabung der situation
und dabei unterscheiden wir zwei
grundsituation in der ersten die wir als
ex ante konkurrenz bezeichnen
gibt es zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
weniger beatmungs plätze als patienten
die auf diese beratungsplätze angewiesen
sind
die ex post situation hingegen
beschreibt die situation dass bereits
alle beatmungs plätze belegt sind und
deshalb ein neuer patient nur versorgt
werden kann wenn die begonnene beratung
eines anderen hierfür beendet wird
diese differenzierung halten wir für
nicht nur in rechtlicher sondern auch
für in moralischer hinsicht bedeutsam
denn im ersten fall kann nur eine
handlungspflicht erfüllt werden es gibt
keine andere option im zweiten hingegen
wurde eine im ergebnis tödliche handlung
vorgenommen
das kann und muss unserer ansicht nach
rechtlich verurteilt werden und
gleichzeitig halten wir das rechtssystem
für flexibel genug um der tragischen
entscheidungssituation rechnung zu
tragen
ärzte sollten mit den in solchen
tragischen situationen die gerade
skizzierten leitplanken von recht und
ethik mit bedenken sie sollten sich
dabei idealerweise sowohl an dem fach
gesellschaftlichen empfehlungen aber
auch an multiprofessionellen teams und
entsprechender beratung durch lokale
ethikkomitees orientieren wir wissen
dass die beschäftigung mit solchen
szenarien ganz reale ängste auslöst das
betrifft nicht nur diejenigen die die
zuteilungen vornehmen müssen also das
medizinische personal
es betrifft auch und gerade diejenigen
die jetzt aktuell befürchten von einer
lebensrettenden maßnahmen von vornherein
ausgeschlossen zu sein leiden gruppen
gegenüber ist die botschaft wichtig dass
unsere gesellschaft ihre nöte und sorgen
anerkennt und sie nicht im stich lässt
so besteht auch
der krise keine veranlassung vertrauen
in den rechtsstaat oder unser
gesundheitssystem zu verlieren meine
damen und herren
neben der trias problematik um nicht zu
sagen
tragik hat der ethikrat in seiner
stellungnahme ein zweites themenfeld
aufgegriffen das in den vergangenen zehn
tagen überaus kontrovers diskutiert
wurde darf deutschland bereits jetzt
über ein ende der kontakt beschränkungen
nachdenken und über die möglichkeit von
lockerungen debattieren
von vielen der entscheidenden
politikerinnen und politikern kommt die
eindeutige aussage üben sie sich in
geduld
der ethikrat hat eine klare position
entwickelt die nach wie vor nach unserer
auffassung bestand hat sie lautet es ist
derzeit noch zu früh für lockerungen
aber es ist nie zu früh für eine
öffentliche diskussion über öffnungs
perspektiven
es stimmt nicht dass man damit den
menschen falsche hoffnungen machen würde
hoffnung hoffnungs bilder brauchen
menschen genau dann wenn sie in einer
katastrophalen situation wie der
jetzigen sind das motiviert zum
durchhalten
darauf haben psychologinnen und
psychologen immer wieder hingewiesen
entscheidend ist welche hoffnungs bilder
in den blick genommen werden und wie sie
kommuniziert werden
vor dem hintergrund der stellungnahme
des ethikrates lässt sich deutlich
erkennen dass die gegenwärtige
kommunikationsstrategie vieler politisch
verantwortlicher zu möglichen
lockerungen oder wie wir es eben einen
öffnungs effektiven
verbesserungsbedürftig ist zu häufig
wird die debatte über öffnungs
perspektiven primär über den zeit aspekt
geführt die sachlichen und sozialen
kriterien werden hinten angestellt
dieser zugang muss geradezu zur
frustration führen
denn immerhin heißt es dann jetzt müssen
wir die lockerungen doch wieder
aufschieben und das
bedroht wenn das wieder passiert die
noch immer hohen zustimmungsraten besser
ist nach unserer sicht ist demgegenüber
die sachlichen notwendigkeiten des
gegenwärtigen lockdown svi seine
sozialen zum teil gravierenden
nebenfolgen in den vordergrund zu
stellen
das heißt konkret immer wieder ehrlich
und kritisch zu überprüfen ob die
maßnahmen für alle oder einzelne gruppen
weiterhin geeignet erforderlich
angemessen kurzum verhältnismäßig sind
das lässt sich nicht abstrakt ein für
alle mal festlegen setzt eine
kontinuierliche politisch moderierte
gesellschaftliche debatte über die
bedeutung unterschiedlicher
schutzwürdiger güter und das maß eines
gesellschaftlich akzeptierten risikos
voraus dabei besteht die eigentliche
herausforderung nicht darin ob leben
oder wirtschaft primär zu sichern seien
die sache ist vielschichtiger wir haben
neben den durch die korona krise
drohenden wirtschaftlichen problemen
schon jetzt solidaritäts konflikte auch
mit blick auf die schutzgüter gesundheit
und leben
der blick auf die notwendigkeit den am
kuhweg 19 erkrankten zu helfen verleitet
bisweilen dazu die opfer des lok downs
aus dem blick zu verlieren
es ist ja nicht nur die wirtschaft die
unsere lebensgrundlage sichert die auf
dem spiel steht wenn wir den lock down
so fortführen nein auch wichtige
operationen oft beschönigende als
effektiv bezeichnet werden verschoben
präventions- untersuchungen werden
abgesagt therapien zur überwindung von
psychischen problemen alkoholsucht
depression gewalt tendenz werden trotz
drohender hoher rückfall
voten unterbrochen sterbende kranke
werden nicht mehr so begleitet wie es
die menschlichkeit erfordert
beerdigungen dieses wichtige ritual der
trauerbewältigung werden oft auf das
unmenschliche empfundene minimum
reduziert existenzen zerbrechen in
einsamkeit oder angesichts empfundene
ausweglosigkeit aus wirtschaftlichen
oder anderen zwangslagen diese
exemplarische aufzählung ließe sich ums
vielfache erweitern
sie macht deutlich die not ist groß die
solidarität ebenfalls aber sie ist nicht
unerschöpflich und sie gerät in konflikt
die maßnahmen die notwendig sind um die
zahl der schweren fälle unterhalb der
intensivmedizinischen kapazitätsgrenzen
zu halten müssen je länger je mehr mit
den schweren gesellschaftlichen sozialen
und psychischen folgen des lok downs
abgeglichen werden
das wird vermutlich nicht bruch frei
gelingen aber wir müssen alles versuchen
den schaden auf beiden seiten möglichst
gering zu halten
wir begrüßen es daher dass seit
erscheinen unserer stellungnahme
weitere initiativen dem gedanken bei
gesprungen sind nach sachlichen zeitlich
örtlichen und sozialen gesichtspunkten
differenziert diese abwägung zwischen
dem medizinisch notwendigen und dem
sozial hinnehmbaren vorzunehmen
wir müssen weg von einem alles oder
nichts denken und handeln
je länger die krise dauert je mehr
stimmen dürfen ja müssen gehört werden
wir sollen keine angst haben vielen
menschen mit unterschiedlichen
kompetenzen aber auch legitime
interessen zu wort kommen zu lassen zum
beispiel wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen die nicht nur aus
den einschlägigen medizinischen
disziplinen
müssen und von denen die öffentlichkeit
nicht erwarten sollte dass sie die
wissenschaft repräsentieren
denn wissenschaft ist immer die
gemeinsame suche nach der besseren
einsicht auf der grundlage des gegebenen
stand der dinge aber auch andere
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
neben den vielfach bekannten
beispielsweise aus den gesundheits und
sozialwissenschaften aus der psychologie
sollten gehört werden und schließlich
vertreterinnen und vertreter von
betroffenen gruppen und schlicht
mitdenkende bürgerinnen und bürger es
darf ja es muss ein ideenwettbewerb der
besten vorschläge geben
eine weithin notwendigen entscheidungs
starken politik schadet es nicht
zuzuhören zu beteiligen und auch grenzen
der eigenen kompetenz anzuerkennen und
dies zu kommunizieren
das stärkt die autorität der politik und
weil politik auch in zeiten der krise
eingebunden sein muss in die
zivilgesellschaft beenden wir unsere
stellungnahme mit dem satz die korona
krise ist die stunde der demokratisch
legitimierten politik vielen dank
den herren die erste frage hat frau
wolff
2000 gästen aus dass für seite genehmigt
bekommen die sie es wohl wünschen sich
indes zum zuschauen haben zwei andere
frage
diskussion mit einem öffentlichen
demonstration umgehend dazu bereit sein
diese information an geräten absagen die
möglichkeit kritische edition ist ab
oder nicht zustellungen ausläuft das
klingt ja
vielen dank zu ihrer ersten frage
aus unserer sicht war es in der letzten
zeit eben nicht ganz so glücklich oder
wie ich es positiv formuliert habe da
besteht verbesserungsbedarf dass man
zunächst von den sachlichen und sozialen
kriterien eher angeht und dann die zeit
dimension betrachtet ich bin ganz bei
ihnen und das ist ja auch etwas was ich
gerade zum schluss noch mal ausdrücklich
betont habe dass ich sehr begrüße dass
viele andere auch die stimme erhoben
haben und auf die sachlichen und die
sozialen dimensionen die sogenannten
kollateralschäden des lockdown
hingewiesen haben
ich hätte mir gewünscht oder wünsche mir
wenn das von der politik tatsächlich
auch als erstes kommuniziert wird weil
ich glaube dass die menschen doch sehr
bereit sind das zeigte auch die
gegenwärtige zustimmung sich von
sachlichen argumenten überzeugen zu
lassen warum
wir zu diesem oder jenem zeitpunkt
tatsächlich den lockdown noch weiter
aufrechterhalten aber es ist viel
sinnvoller primär das sachliche und
sozialer zu nennen weil man dann nicht
in den rechtfertigungszwang hineingerät
dass man sagt naja wir sagen jetzt 14
april oder das nachbarland hat 14 april
gesagt oder wer seinen 19 april und dann
merken wir plötzlich die zahlen sind
aber nicht so dass wir diesen termin
einhalten können und dann führt das zu
einer frustration und diese frustration
erst gar nicht sozusagen zu motivieren
das ist unser hinweis und mit blick auf
die verhältnismäßigkeit der der
einschränkungen gerade das für die
demokratie so wichtigen demonstrations-
prinzips und der meinungsfreiheit
er zeigt sich wieder dass je länger je
mehr die rechtfertigung bedürftigkeit
für den showdown steigt weil natürlich
ganz wichtige elementare rechte der
politischen partizipation nicht auf
dauer vollständig negiert werden können
und man muss dann tatsächlich schauen
wie man das in ein verhältnis bringt mit
dem aus unserer sicht gegenwärtig
gebotenen gesundheitsschutz und dem
versuch die kapazitätsgrenzen der
intensivmedizin nicht zu überreizen
wenn ich dafür nicht ganz gerne kurz
zwei punkte ergänzen zu ihren beiden
fragen das erste ist in der tat dass wir
das hat kader angesprochen
auch ein desiderat in der diskussion
über das maß des gesellschaftlich
akzeptierten risiko sehen und das findet
so nehme ich das jedenfalls war noch
nicht in der form statt wie man sich das
wünschen würde das ist eine
ausgesprochen schwierige frage weil das
impliziert dass wir uns zunächst mal
darüber gedanken machen welche risiken
wir eigentlich normalerweise also
außerhalb unserer jetzigen
krisensituation hinzunehmen bereit sind
es ist aber notwendige voraussetzungen
glaube ich dafür dass man irgendetwas
zurückkommt was man wieder als als als
quasi normalität gewissermaßen sehen
wird unter umständen wären wir bestimmt
bereichen auch besser sein als vor der
krise aber jedenfalls wird es nicht mehr
so sein wie es mal war darüber müssen
wir glaube ich wirklich intensiv
nachdenken der zweite punkt ist die
frage zur versammlungs- und
meinungsfreiheit das sind
selbstverständlich nicht nur hochwertige
grundrechte sondern auch im
demokratischen staat wichtige garantien
also funktional auch irgendwie
keineswegs klein zu reden und
gleichzeitig muss man an der schilder
etwas vorsichtig sein mit der teilweise
jetzt irgendwie zu gewärtigen denn
fundamental kritik die sich bei manchen
ja so liest als wären wir gewissermaßen
wieder auf dem weg in diktatorischen
verhältnisse das kann unsere demokratie
ab wenn wir eine weile lang nicht
demonstrieren dürfen
das ist nicht wünschenswert dass es
grund rechtlich bedenklich und es gibt
insofern gute gründe das wieder
zurückzufahren
aber es ist andererseits auch das würde
ich schon mit blick auf die zahlreichen
menschen unserem land sagen wollen die
vor ganz wirklich enormen existenziellen
sorgen stehen auch nicht das zentrale
problem was wir zur zeit bewältigen
müssen
wir können und wir sollten in der
situation wie auch anderenorts versuchen
möglichst innovativ zu sein und die
wichtigen politischen korrektiv
funktionen die von solchen grundrechten
ausgehen auf andere weise ausleben und
das lässt sich unter umständen im
bereich von von demonstrationen
meinungsfreiheit besser substituieren
als in anderen kontexten sie können ganz
schlecht ein kleines kind das auf dem
spielplatz möchte vor den fernseher
setzen und sagen das ist das gleiche
aber sie können relativ gut über
petitionen online-abstimmung etc
einen ähnlichen effekt erzielen wie bei
der demonstration also da wäre ich
insofern auch hoffnungsfroh aber alles
vor dem hintergrund das ist natürlich
nicht irgendwie langfristig so anhält
die technik ist leider auch etwas vom
virus infiziert und tut nicht was sie
soll deshalb gibt's hier hilfe die
nächste und ich kann deshalb im moment
auch keine fragen von außen vorlesen
aber ich bin hoffnungsvoll dass das bald
wieder geht freeborn ist die nächste
[Musik]
vielen dank
es hängt natürlich eng miteinander
zusammen also wir haben versucht
einerseits diese perspektive die wir so
als als objektive im entscheidungs
parameter überzeichnet würden zu
benennen und andererseits das runter zu
brechen auf diese subjektive ebene die
letztlich die strafrechtlicher ist die
sie ansprechen
die strafrechtliche verantwortung ist
natürlich eine ganz zentrale weil die
mediziner in der tat befürchten dass sie
mit solchen entscheidungen in
grenzsituationen auch der der
strafrechtlichen verantwortung kommen
und bis zu einem gewissen punkt würde
ich sagen ist das so und bis zu einem
gewissen punkt ist das auch gut so
die ehrfurcht vor dem leben und die
furcht hang nicht nur ideologisch
zusammen wir müssen an dieser stelle
tatsächlich gewärtigen dass es um eine
elementare und besonders problematische
entscheidungssituation geht und deshalb
ist es zunächst einmal gut dass wir
damit auch einen einen hohen respekt und
gegebenenfalls auch ein wenig sorge
verbinden und auf der anderen seite ist
es aber selbstredend so dass man diesen
menschen die jetzt da an der frontlinie
gewissermaßen stehende die eine aufgabe
übernehmen bei der jedenfalls ich froh
bin dass ich das nicht machen muss dass
wir den hilfestellungen leisten wollen
dass wir ihm zu sichern wollen dass sie
nicht völlig allein gelassen werden und
die antwort die aus unserer sicht an
dieser stelle das rechtssystem gibt ist
eine zweigeteilte wir können auf der
einen seite weil wir an der
gleichwertigkeit des lebens zu
festhängen weil wir gerade diese
kriterien
auch der erfolgsaussichten auch der der
gebrechlichkeit für problematisch
erachten wenn man sie radikalisiert und
pauschalisiert deshalb wollen wir
einerseits daran festhalten dass wir
sagen diese entscheidung sind für solche
als solche sehen nicht rechtmäßig nicht
vom recht als die richtigen vorgesehen
aber auf der anderen seite müssen wir im
rechtssystem anerkennen dass es gute
gründe nicht rechtlicher art geben kann
dass man sich so entscheidet an der
stelle zeigt sich gewissermaßen dass es
eben durchaus plausibel sein kann dass
eine rechtliche einschätzung die an
bestimmten für unhintergehbare
gehaltenen grund kategorien festhält und
eine moralische einschätzung durchaus
reagieren können und das recht ist
flexibel genug dann für diese
moralischen kategorien auch aufnahme
felder zu finden das bedeutet insofern
dass wir uns so wird das bei uns
formuliert mit nachsicht der
rechtsordnung rechnen können das können
die strafrechtlichen kollegen vermutlich
besser erklären wie sich das genau
vorstellen als ich mein verständnis dazu
ist dass es im prinzip um einen notstand
kategorien geht und gegebenenfalls aber
eben nicht darum zu sagen das ist jetzt
etwas was wir als als rechtmäßig
anerkennen und es schlägt um in diese
oder beantwortet glaube ich dazu
jedenfalls zum teil auch ihre zweite
frage nach dem aussortieren
ich glaube dass ein solches aussortieren
von rechtswegen in hohem maße bedenklich
ist die kategorien die dazu führen dass
wir von vornherein bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen als gewissermaßen
nicht beatmungs fähig irgendwie ein teil
ist mit der vorstellung einer
prinzipiellen gleichwertigkeit des
menschlichen lebens nicht vorstellen
nicht zusammen zu führen das heißt nicht
dass nicht vieles irgendwie auch in
medizinischer hinsicht relevant wird
natürlich über die indikationsstellung
etwa abgedeckt wird aber vorab und
pauschal gewissermaßen gruppen zu bilden
und zu sagen diese fallen nicht darunter
und diese schon das ist ausgesprochen
bedenklich und da setzt dann tatsächlich
dieser rechtliche imperativ ein zu sagen
wir verlangen eine entsprechende
gleichbehandlung und daran müssen wir
als gesellschaft auch festhalten meinen
wir meinen dass diese eine verletzung
solcher grundlegender maßgaben des
rechts für die gesellschaft mindestens
ebenso wird zu gefährlich wäre wie
vereinzelte tragische situation
ich habe jetzt hier erst 24 jetzt fünf
wortmeldungen und sechs von den kollegen
die uns am bildschirm verfolgen
ich schiebe ich mal erst mal eine frage
von außen dazwischen frau schützt simon
schmitz von der bild zeitung fragt wieso
ist es so schwer gesundheitsschutz und
freiheits schutz zu vereinen sorgt sie
dass die massnahmen teils absurde
ausmaße annehmen drohneneinsatz
beschränkungen für zeit auf park banken
und solche sachen
und der protest gegen solche
absurditäten und unnötigen
freiheitsbeschränkungen ausbleibt
offensichtlich erleben wir dass es
schwer ist gesundheitsschutz und
freiheit schutz gegenwärtig
zusammenzubringen und ich glaube es tut
uns allen gut in der öffentlichkeit in
der in der medienwelt die diese
öffentlichkeit ja herstellt als auch in
der politik wahrzunehmen und uns
einzugestehen dass der ausgleich der oft
schon in normalen zeiten schwer fällt in
diesen tagen besonders schwer fällt und
ich nehme bisher auch von dem was sich
aus den umfragen gehört habe in der
bevölkerung ein hohes maß an zustimmung
für die gegenwärtigen maßnahmen war aber
man muss sich auch vor augen halten und
das ist relativ und schwer zu
prognostizieren wenn man das nicht
kontinuierlich überprüft ist das ganze
noch verhältnismäßig und wenn man nicht
die jeweiligen maßnahmen von ihrer
sachlichen notwendigkeit und auch ein
blick auf die sozialen nebenfolgen in
auch nochmal evaluiert das man dann
tatsächlich in die gefahr hinein läuft
das nicht nur die zustimmung in der
bevölkerung abnimmt sondern dass das
auch einen dialektischen gegenschlag
geben könnte und das dann wirklich zu
einem ganz erheblichen maß an
unzufriedenheit führt deswegen ist es
uns ja so wichtig auf diese
kommunikationsstrategien hinzuweisen die
bevölkerung mitzunehmen partizipation
wirklich als ein inneres gut des
politischen prozesses zu begreifen und
ich glaube dann sind wir am ehesten in
der lage diese schwierige balance da bin
ich ganz bei frau schütz einigermaßen
mit wenig schaden durch diese sehr
schwere zeit hindurch zu bringen dann
schließlich das stichwort
kommunikationsstrategie gleich noch eine
frage der kollegin schweizer vom ard
hauptstadtstudio an die nämlich wissen
möchte wie sie die kommunikation der
bundeskanzlerin bewerten etwa anhand der
gestrigen pressekonferenz
also bevor ich da einfach so finde ich
gut finde ich nicht antwortete ist es
mir einfach wichtig auch als ein
vertreter eines gremiums das versucht
einen resonanzraum von öffentlichkeit
für die politik darzustellen wirklich
die hohe anerkennung für das was die
bundesregierung die landesregierungen
derzeit leisten zum ausdruck zu bringen
das ist aus meiner und auch aus der
sicht des ethikrates alles andere als
selbstverständlich und ich glaube das
muss man zunächst erst mal tatsächlich
so wahrnehmen
vor diesem hintergrund finde ich es
tatsächlich nochmal verbesserungsfähig
wenn man zum einen stärker die
sachlichen perspektiven in den blick
nimmt wenn man den menschen auch das
noch stärker das gefühl gibt nicht nur
ich denke tag und nacht darüber nach was
wir tun können sondern ich freue mich zu
hören was sie denken was sie als
einzelne denken was sie in den gruppen
in den gemeinschaften
in denen sie sich engagieren denken und
was sie aus dieser arbeit heraus uns der
regierung für die bewältigung dieser
schwierigen situation mit auf den weg
geben
darüber kann jetzt nachgedacht werden
und das ist noch kein vorwegnehmen und
eine falsche hoffnung machen und in der
hinsicht wünsche ich mir noch mehr
mitnehmen der bevölkerung
der kollege
[Musik]
eigentlich gut antwortet wer sich
berufen fühlt in der stellungnahme zur
ohne krise hat der deutsche ethikrat
selbst nicht unmittelbar auf die von
ihnen genannten fragen geantwortet wir
haben aber kurz vorher also wenige
wochen zuvor gegen eine stellungnahme zu
guter pflege und robotik veröffentlicht
und das konzept unter pflegen was wir
dort in den mittelpunkt gestellt haben
ist ein solches konzept das die
bedeutung der beziehungs dimension in
der pflege besonders hoch stellt und
würdigt das heißt es geht also nicht nur
darum dass man im medizinisch
pflegerischen sinne sagen vorrichtungen
vornimmt sondern fliege ist ein caring
ist also wirklich beziehungs sorge bis
fürsorge arbeit wenn ich dieses konzept
aufgreife und noch mal mit ein punkt aus
unserer stellungnahme zur krone krise
zusammenbringen
dann teilen wir jedenfalls die großen
sorgen die gestern in einer bekannten
fernseh diskussionssendung am abend über
die rolle der menschen in der pflege zum
ausdruck gebracht worden sind ich glaube
dieser punkt ist einer dem wir ganz
erheblich mehr aufmerksamkeit zuwenden
müssen nicht nur was die
mortalitätsraten in den pflegeheimen an
betrifft sondern auch was die wirklich
grad
währenden psychischen ich nenne es
wirklich so kollateralschäden anbetrifft
von depression von vereinsamung von
deutlicher verschlechterung auch des
kognitiven zustandes durch den umstand
dass man eben nicht mehr in dem maße in
dem man es gewohnt ist stimuli erhält um
eben weiter seinen ressourcen
orientiertes modell guten alterns leben
zu können das ist glaube ich eine
dimension die wir öffentlich jetzt
debattieren müssen und genau aus dem
grunde bin ich auch so dafür dass wir
diese diskussionen gegenwärtig führen um
uns genau auch wechselseitig zu
informieren was auf der einen oder
anderen seite auf dem spiel steht statt
sozusagen ein tunnelblick zu haben mit
blick auf das was wir jetzt gerade
durchführen müssen wir müssen einfach
unsere perspektive zum wohle genau auch
der wohlhabenden gruppen in der
gesellschaft weiten also mit der
häuslichen gewalt windig ist es
ausgesprochen schwierig wir haben das in
der stellungnahme angesprochen als
problem wir sehen dass eben als einen
den punkt der punkte die mit einbezogen
werden in diese gesamtabwägung dessen zu
sagen unter welchen bedingungen können
wir eigentlich wieder zurück zu normalen
zuständen
ihre frage war glaube ich noch etwas
konkreter danach was man tun kann damit
diese gewalt in den familien nicht
stattfindet da sind wir als gremium
glaube ich überfragt da müsste man
andere institutionen fragen das
geschieht ja teilweise auch das
hilfestellung geleistet werden wie man
sich einigermaßen sinnvoll beschäftigen
kann also jetzt über die schulaufgaben
und sowas hinaus aber diese form von von
individueller frustration bekämpfung das
was die erwachsenen angeht und irgendwie
beschäftigungen war was die kinder und
jugendlichen
angeht und vielleicht auch
frustrationstoleranz lernen das ist
etwas was wir als gremium glaube ich
kaum leisten können wir sind eher dafür
da die sensibilität in der gesellschaft
dafür aufrecht zu halten dass es dort
schwierigkeiten gibt und das haben wir
glaube ich getan wenn ich das richtig
verstehe geht das dann so ein bisschen
an die kollegen den saal
ich kann ihnen zum fernsehen man jetzt
entsprechende nutzung nicht sagen aber
ich habe sofort im radio das gefühl dass
es da durchaus ganz intensive bemühungen
aufgegeben hat das programm umzustellen
und eben sich darauf einzustellen dass
ganz viele kinder und jugendliche
insbesondere jetzt zu hause sind und
entsprechende symbole wie wir das eben
für eine andere bevölkerungsgruppe
gehört haben auch zu haben
also ich sehe diese aktivitäten im
medialen bereich verbessern ausweiten
kann man sicherlich immer vieles so mit
einem blick auf die uhr gehe ich jetzt
mal weiter verringert das wort
wir haben das europäische und
internationale probleme tatsächlich mit
in den blick genommen
wir beschäftigen uns aber tatsächlich
zunächst mal mit der rechtlichen und
ethischen einschätzung für deutschland
und insofern sind natürlich auch
insbesondere die rechtlichen vorgaben
solche die sich auf das geld des
deutschen grundgesetzes beziehen und die
insoweit primär nicht die deutschen im
sinne einer staatsbürgerschaft sondern
die in deutschland lebenden personen
betreffen also das ist eine wichtige
differenzierung jemand vorab vornehmen
muss das ist eine innereuropäische
solidarität geben muss gegeben
internationale solidarität geben muss
ist ein dann davon abweichen da
zusätzlicher punkt wir können auch
hinsichtlich der korona krise nicht alle
probleme in deutschland lösen wir können
nicht die patienten der welt nach
deutschland holen und damit
konkurrenzsituationen erzeugen unter
denen dann die hiesigen bürgerinnen und
bürger also nochmal inclusive gedacht
unabhängig von der staatsangehörigkeit
leiden würden das heißt aber nicht dass
wir nicht eine verantwortung haben nach
möglichkeit auch zu helfen deshalb ist
glaube ich das was zurzeit geschieht
dass man versucht sich zu öffnen
jedenfalls punktuell den nachbarländern
oder auch italien irgendwie
bereitzustehen ausgesprochen sinnvoll
ist aber eine verantwortung rechtlich
oder ethisch art dahingehend dass wir
unsere kapazitäten
allen gegebenenfalls sogar weltweit zur
verfügung stellen müssen das wäre glaube
ich den bogen deutlich überspannt was
man allerdings auch sagen kann und das
ist finde ich eine interessante
erkenntnis dieser krise ist dass die
gesundheitssysteme insgesamt doch sehr
stark national orientiert sind also die
ganz erheblichen unterschiede im
innereuropäischen raum etwa was die
ausstattung mit intensivbetten angeht
sind ja etwas über das man auch
langfristig nachdenken kann das mag eine
bewusste entscheidung der einzelnen
gesellschaften seien
das erzeugt aber natürlich auch
entsprechende solidaritäts konflikt wie
wir sie insgesamt behandelt haben vielen
dank für ihre frage
für ihre zwei fragen ich habe die die
verhältnis bestimmung zwischen der
gruppe die man abschließen soll also
ziehen wir uns alle zurück oder soll man
die risiko die hochrisikogruppen dazu
auffordern in eine selbstisolation zu
gehen
da scheint mir für die mittelfristige
perspektive
eine der wichtigsten fragen zu sein
ich glaube kurzfristig sind die meisten
sich einig dass man mit einer strategie
wie sie am anfang in england gefahren
worden ist wie sie in holland gefahren
worden ist wie seine zeit in schweden
noch gefahren worden ist man zu schnell
die kapazitätsgrenzen überschreiten
würde und man auf die art und weise
viele hunderttausend am opfer in kauf
nehmen würde so was man von den
entsprechenden epidemiologen lesen kann
wenn das für die kurzfristige
perspektive geld muss das nicht auch vor
dem hintergrund dass wir gesagt haben
dass man ja immer step by step
überprüfen muss ob die maßnahmen greifen
oder nicht greifen muss das nicht heißen
dass dass damit automatisch mittel und
langfristig so gilt und an der stelle
halte ich es auch für geboten dass man
neben der fachwissenschaftlichen auch
eine gesellschaftliche debatte dazu
führt weil wenn man nur eine
fachwissenschaftliche debatte dazu führt
und nicht in die gesellschaft solche
überlegungen überhaupt ein spielt was
sind die vor
was sind die nachteile wenn man versucht
diese zwei farben möglichst bruch frei
miteinander zeigen auszubalancieren dann
kann das nur dazu führen dass das zu und
zwar ganz erheblichen protest und zu
sozialen verwerfungen führt deswegen
glaube ich ist das wichtigste was er als
als botschaft rüber kommen muss dass man
zunächst erst mal versucht wenn man so
etwas erwägt es über freiwilligkeit zu
machen dass es nicht über zwang geht das
würde nach meinem verständnis jedenfalls
den den der grundrechtlichen
verfassungsgemäßen orientierung unseres
gemeinwesens am gut der freiheit
entsprechen
dann muss aber auch darüber nachgedacht
werden wenn man tatsächlich über solche
selbst isolierungen nachdenkt da darf
ich den einsatz mit der gefährdeten der
gefährdeten wenn man über die selbst
isolierung der gefährdeten nachdenkt
dann muss man auch in erwägung ziehen
dass wir ja damit nicht nur wie es immer
heißt dann die rentnerinnen und rentner
haben sondern wir haben ja auch im
arbeitenden teil der bevölkerung viele
die zu risikogruppen gehören
das sind diejenigen die
lungenkrankheiten haben die gerade eine
krebstherapie durchlaufen die eine
autoimmunerkrankung haben und so weiter
und so fort
und ich bin mir nicht sicher das hielt
sich auch für eine aufgabe das zu
überprüfen dass bei all denen
entsprechende versorgung im
krankheitsfall über die gesetzlich
vorgegebene frist hinaus abgesichert ist
und wenn wir unternehmen unter den
schutzschirm stellen dann müssen wir
auch gucken dass arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer die freiwillig zum wohle
des ganzen sich zurückziehen dann auch
nicht in ihrer existenz gefährdet werden
das hielte ich tatsächlich dann auch für
eine überlegung wie man mit
berücksichtigen müsste und vor allen
dingen müssen diese dinge tatsächlich
gesellschaftlich debattiert werden denn
es kann tatsächlich sein dass wir
mittelfristig sonst in ein solches
problem volkswirtschaftliche art
hineinlaufen dass wir wenn wir die
volkswirtschaftliche überhaupt nicht
mehr in gang bekommen
das jedenfalls wir deuten dass in
unserer stellungnahme auch an einer
stelle an über solche selbst isolierung
der gefährdeten tatsächlich nachgedacht
werden muss das ist aber wie mehr
rückmeldungen aus sogenannten
hochrisikogruppen zu unserer
stellungnahme bereits gezeigt haben
alles andere als leicht und deswegen
brauchen wir darüber eben auch eine
debatte um überhaupt ansatzweise
akzeptanz für soetwas gegebenenfalls zu
fördern
es gibt zu dieser frage kontakt sperren
risikogruppen und so einige
fragen von den kolleginnen und kollegen
von außerhalb ich versuche dir mal ein
bisschen zu bündeln weil sie ja jetzt
auch schon einiges dazu gesagt haben
meerholz von der bild -zeitung die
kollegin fragt sollte die kontaktsperre
für alte und risikopatienten zugunsten
der anderen länger bestehen bleiben
frau brandes von der berliner zeitung
fragt wie bewerten sie die überlegung
nur ältere menschen in ihrer
bewegungsfreiheit einzuschränken
auch um die wirtschaft wieder
anzukurbeln kann man rechte nur für eine
bevölkerungsgruppe beschränken aus
moralischer sicht
michael gabel vom ndr fragt nach dem
lock down ist es zulässig kontakt
beschränkung nur für ältere zu erlassen
um die wirtschaft und anderes wieder in
gang zu bringen was halten sie von
bestimmten einkaufszeiten speziell für
ältere
dann habe ich eine frage nach einem
solidaritätskonzert der oder diejenige
könnte sich noch mal lauten wer das ist
dann kann ich die frage auch stellen ist
es glaube ich hier noch nachgeliefert
worden
und das ist noch mal neu reingekommen
und dann noch eine kommunikations frage
dass wer also zu den zu den
hochrisikogruppen insbesondere zu den
älteren ist ja zunächst und im ausgang
zu sagen dass es einerseits ganz
bewundernswert und im überaus erfreulich
ist wie in unserer gesellschaft darüber
bislang eigentlich nicht diskutiert wird
dass wir unsere gesamte gesellschaft
herunterfahren um einen teil der
bevölkerung zu schützen das ist ein
ausdruck eines solidarischen verhaltens
in der gesamtbevölkerung der ja
keineswegs selbstverständlich ist das
ist glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger punkt
der zweite aspekt den man
berücksichtigen muss ist das allerdings
deutlich zu kurz gegriffen wenn man das
nur als generationenkonflikt versteht
sondern wir müssen natürlich auch sehen
dass diese besonders gefährdeten
personen ihrerseits wenn sie denn in
hohem maße mit konterangriffen 19
erkrankten und entsprechend behandelt
werden müssten natürlich auch
gesamtrisiken erzeugt das heißt in dem
moment in dem die intensivstationen voll
sind mit entsprechenden patienten können
auch andere patienten die vielleicht gar
nichts mit 19 zu tun haben ein schlecht
versorgt werden dann wird das ganze zu
einem gesamt systemischen problem
insofern ist es glaube ich auch nicht
richtig wenn wir das einordnete nur als
ein problem der selbst
es geht nicht darum dass man sagen kann
er ich bin doch erwachsen genug und ich
traue mir das eben zu und vielleicht
kann ich auch von mir selbst sagen ich
habe mein leben lang genug gelebt und
möchte deshalb jetzt dieses risiko ganz
bewusst auch für mich ein gehen sondern
es geht tatsächlich darum dass wir das
haben wir eben ja kurz behandelt knappe
im wortsinne knappe ressourcen verteilen
müssen und weil wir solidarisch agieren
wollen ist es glaube ich aus der
moralischen perspektive das war ja die
frage durchaus vorstellbar dass man da
auch besondere appelle an besondere
gruppen richtet das heißt noch lange
nicht und da bin ich ganz bei herrn
dabrock dass man das jetzt als zwangs
modell etabliert sondern es geht
letztlich darum dass man zumindestens
die aufmerksamkeit darauf für erhöht
dass hier auch eine spezifische
verantwortung der besonders gefährdeten
nicht nur für sich sondern auch für die
gesamte gesellschaft besteht wie das im
einzelnen umgesetzt wird ob das
überhaupt praktikabel und sinnvoll ist
darüber muss man sicherlich jetzt im
weiteren verlauf nachdenken
aber wenn wir insgesamt in diesem
ideenwettbewerb über den harderberg
gesprochen hat uns gedanken darüber
machen wie wir wieder rauskommen aus der
gegenwärtigen eskalation logik immer
mehr irgendwie an beschränkung maßnahmen
und länger als wir das vielleicht
ursprünglich mal gedacht haben dann
müssen wir natürlich auch über solche
konstellationen nachdenken und ich
glaube in der tat wenn man sich vor
augen hält dass es nicht nur um
selbstgefährdung sondern auch eine
fremdgefährdung geht dann ist das eine
form von solidarität die man auch dieser
bevölkerungsgruppe entgegenhalten oder
man jemand von ihr erwarten kann und in
gewisser weise würde sogar sagen dass es
ein ernstnehmen dieser person dass wir
sagen dass es genau das was wir von euch
erwarten wir seit eben nicht nur die
wohlhabenden die wir schützen müssen
sondern ihr habt auch eine wesentliche
aufgabe entsprechend hier irgendwie in
dieses gesamtkonzept mit einbezogen zu
werden
ob einkaufszeiten dafür das richtige
mittel der wahl sind weiß ich nicht aber
das ist sicherlich dann so ein kleiner
baustein unter umständen wie man das
ganze so strukturieren kann dass es
funktioniert ohne dass man damit was ihr
nun wirklich irgendwie alles andere als
erstrebenswert wäre die generationen
ganz strikt voneinander abtrennen
gut dann mache ich mir im saal weiter
frau ludwig tschuldigung hat sich
festgesetzt
entschuldigung
mai steht das eben bei dieser
entscheidung auf mobilität eine rolle
spielen soll
unter den tischen
vielen dank
ich bin mir nicht sicher das ist auch
eine medizinische frage die ich mal
nicht qualifiziert beantworten zu können
ob die entsprechende ausrüstung dieselbe
ist so wie ich es verstanden habe
jedenfalls die beatmungsgeräte die
immobilie ambulant verwendet werden sind
glaube ich für die weko mit 19
behandlungen nicht tauglich also das ist
eine andere form von von beatmung um
dies an der stelle geht ich glaube nicht
dass das die knappheit situation ist
aber sie haben natürlich recht wenn sie
sagen dass dort einfach die betreuung
knapp wird und dann gegebenenfalls eine
entsprechende behandlung in der klinik
erforderlich würde dann trägt das zu der
gesamtproblematik bei in der tat und
dann sind sie und die beiden fragen
glaube ich gut miteinander verknüpfen
dann sind sieht man in der situation
dass das natürlich eine spezifische form
von wenn sie wollen komorbidität wäre zu
sagen da ist bereits eine vorerkrankung
gegeben das hat jetzt mit der konkreten
pandemie situation gar nichts zu tun und
gleichzeitig sind auch in der
perspektive natürlich die frage zu
stellen wie diese ressourcen verteilt
werden können es ist nicht sinnvoll
glaube ich tatsächlich zu sagen dass
diese die diese ressourcen knappheit
sich nur auf eine patientengruppe
bezieht das wäre völlig unplausibel
sondern sie müssen natürlich in der tat
sagen
darüber hinaus muss eine allgemeine
verteilungs entscheidung erfolgen und
dafür sind die kriterien schwer zu
bestimmen und was wir verdeutlichen
wollten ist das einfach in dieser ex
ante situation mehrere brauchen das
gleiche da ist nur eine pflicht erfüllt
das ist irgendwie eine tragische
natürlich situationen aber es nur einer
firma bei dem anderen geht es um das was
sie so ein bisschen umgangssprachlich
als abstöpseln bezeichnet haben was aber
natürlich die dramatik irgendwie ja auch
ein bisschen wie umschreibt er geht
tatsächlich um eine todbringende
handlung die für die ich vornehme und in
der situation über die wir sprechen wo
es nicht um eine von einer einwilligung
getragene also von patienten gewünschte
nicht fortsetzung etwa der beatmung er
geht sondern musste auch geht dass ein
dritter hinzu tritt und diese handlung
vornimmt da ist das von zentraler
bedeutung ob es um eine unterlassung
oder
eine handlung geht und was die
empfehlungen der fachgesellschaften
angeht die muss man glaube ich vor dem
hintergrund auch durchaus kritisch lesen
in der tat dazu gibt es mittlerweile ja
auch kritische stimmen so wertvoll dass
im prinzip ist das auch aus
medizinischer sicht handreichungen
getroffen werden so sehr müssen wir
natürlich vor dem hintergrund unseres
allgemeinen grundsatzes der lebenswert
indifferenz genau gucken was das
eigentlich bedeutet ich hatte das vorhin
angedeutet wir sagen wir wollen eben
keine pauschale ausgrenzung von
bevölkerungsgruppen und wenn der
gebrechlichkeit index oder die crew
mobilitäts orientierung dazu führt dass
bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen von
vornherein gewissermaßen chancenlos sind
ohne anblick der konkreten situation
dann würden wir das vermutlich auch als
wir nicht mehr akzeptieren können die
angedeutete schwierigkeit besteht
allerdings darin dass unter umständen in
einer ganz konkreten situation etwas was
wir als rechtlich inakzeptabel
brandmarken uns trotzdem moralisch noch
sinnvoll sein kann und sei es nur dass
man sagt man hat zumindest irgendeine
leitlinie aber im prinzip würde ich
dabei bleiben zu sagen diese pauschale
ausgrenzung von bevölkerungsgruppen die
es in jedem falle nicht hinnehmbar bei
den behinderungen muss man natürlich
dann stark differenzieren wie das enden
sich auswirkt aber das ist die
grundposition wäre die zu sagen wir
können nicht dazu kommen und zwar auch
nicht aus medizinischer sicht was eher
einer medizinisch auch nur teilweise zu
begründen ist dass eine solche
vorauswahl erfolgt dann geht es weiter
mit frank mischo
der weg darstellung dabei hängt unser
beider herzen als er diese krone
empfehlung und das ist natürlich eine
etwas andere konstellation ich würde
noch mal auf den aspekt der innovations-
offenheit hinweisen wollen ich glaube
dass wir tatsächlich an der stelle
gut beraten sind alles was uns irgendwie
helfen kann zu nutzen und zwar so zu
nutzen dass wir selbstverständlich nicht
aus dem blick verlieren was wir an
grundlegenden wertvorstellungen haben
also auch die krise führt weder dazu
dass die demonstrationsfreiheit
irgendwie außer kraft gesetzt wird
irgendwie noch 14 dazu dass wir mit
persönlichkeitsrechten irgendwie
datenschutz nichts mehr zu tun haben
wurde das für völlig irrelevant erachten
aber wir müssen natürlich trotzdem
schauen inwieweit ist hier innerhalb der
grenzen dessen was wir insoweit als
rechtskonform irgendwie akzeptieren
möglichkeiten gibt das auszubauen da bin
ich völlig dafür ich halte das auch für
für sinnvoll ich glaube auch dass die
stellungnahme etwa des
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten der doch
relativ proaktiv irgendwie und aus
meiner sicht auch irgendwie erstaunlich
zustimmend gewissermaßen reagiert hat da
ganz hilfreich ist zu sagen dass man
sich nicht von vornherein den blick
verbaut auf möglichkeiten wir sind auch
diesbezüglich nicht auf dem weg in einen
überwachungsstaat es geht nicht darum
dass wir mit den jetzt diskutierten
möglichkeiten irgendjemand hat vorhin im
wie drohnen erwähnt aber dass wir in
einem kontext uns befinden wo
gewissermaßen wir alle unsere
grundrechte einschließlich der
informationellen selbstbestimmung
gewissermaßen abgegeben haben sondern
wir müssen diese im prinzip natürlich
aufrecht erhalten aber gerade deshalb
sind wir berufen hiernach eigentlich
interessanten und irgendwie innovativen
lösungen zu forschen und ich halte die
apps insoweit durchaus für ein
interessantes modell sie kommen wenn ich
es richtig verstehe etwas spät aber das
ist nun in der gesamtsituation sowie
keine keine besonderheit weil unser
beider herzen dieser stellungnahme hängt
frau b schon noch eine kurze ergänzung
der ethikrat hatte in seiner
stellungnahme diktator und gesundheit
vor allen dingen das konzept der daten
souveränität stark gemacht und das war
der versuch den gedanken des
datenschutzes für das big data und kein
zeitalter wetterfest zu machen und es
gehört vermutlich auch zu den bisher
noch nicht eingegangen
innovationsmöglichkeiten aber wenn man
dieses konzept zu dem wir auch
technische umsetzungen vorgeschlagen
haben sich vielleicht nochmal anschaut
weil dann wäre auch ein kurzfristiger
einsatz wie er ursprünglich von herrn
spahn gedacht war durchaus möglich weil
nämlich der einzelnen die daten
souveränität behält wenn daten von ihm
überhaupt verwendet werden das ist
vielleicht dann doch noch mal wie in
vielen anderen bereichen
versorgungsbereichen wo wir jetzt
festgestellten mensch da haben wir
lücken da müssen wir nach der krise noch
mal darüber nachdenken das bedinge
vielleicht noch mal neu aufstellen auch
ein bereich dass wir genau aufgrund
solcher pandemischer ereignisse uns noch
gedanken machen wie wir tatsächlich
einerseits aber die möglichkeiten von
diktator am ki nutzen und andererseits
aber auch standards der souveränität des
daten subjekt es auch weiter halten und
das scheint mir auch noch weiter
notwendig zu sein darüber nachzudenken
naja wenn das infektionsschutzgesetz das
grundsätzlich ermöglicht dann sehe ich
durch die technische möglichkeit
insbesondere dann wenn es wie es jetzt
geplant ist den gegenwärtigen
gesetzlichen und technischen
rahmenbedingungen sicher auch sinnvoll
ist auf freiwilligkeit ebene geschieht
und ich gehe mal davon aus dass viele in
der bevölkerung sagen werden auch aus
der aufgrund der breiten solidarität die
wir gerade haben da machen wir mit
dann ist das technisch weil es ja auf
der grundlage der freiwilligkeit ist
etwas was im rahmen des infektionsgefahr
infektionsschutzgesetzes wäre
der kollege hat sich geoutet
die in frage ohne namen geschickt hatte
und zwar fragt der kollege von dpa zum
thema solidaritäts konflikt in dieser
krise über die sie über denen sie
gesprochen haben
sehen sie auch ein solidaritäts konflikt
zwischen jung und alt und eine frage an
herrn professor augsburg könnten sie
noch einmal in einem satz oder kurz
zusammenfassen was konkret die
empfehlung des ethikrates beim thema
triage ist sozusagen eine kleine
arbeitshilfen für die kollegen wie man
die wie die überschrift dann formulieren
370 zeichen schließe ich aus wer immer
sich angesprochen fühlt das teilen dann
kannst du noch ein bisschen über die 270
zeichen nachdenken das sind immer
schwieriger heraus märkte das finde ich
vorhin
sehr gut dargestellt als er gesagt hat
dass die weite bevölkerung derzeit ein
hohes maß an solidarität übt auch mit
blick auf gefährdung der eigenen
wirtschaftlichen existenz für eine
risikogruppe zu der nicht ausschließlich
aber doch in einem hohen maße ältere
menschen gehören
insofern ist es richtig dass wir
konstatieren können das derzeit in die
richtung ein hohes maß an solidarität
fließt und es gab einen kollegen von
ihnen der in der süddeutschen zeitung
vor anderthalb wochen noch zwei andere
bereiche deutlich gemacht hat wo das
derzeit auch der fall ist nämlich im
bereich der darüber mag man streiten
im bereich klima und im bereich renten
jedenfalls im bereich kohle krise haben
wir derzeit ein gewissen solidaritäts
fluss in die richtung aber herr augsburg
hat auch darauf hingewiesen
es wäre ganz verkürzt wenn man die
gegenwärtigen ich will zunächst erst mal
sagen solidarität spannungen die zu
solidaritäts konflikten führen wenn man
sie alleine auf das raster alt versus
jung reduzieren würde
das würde eine unnötige und in der
schwierigen gesellschaftlichen lage nur
nochmals verschärfen die reaktion
hervorrufen und von daher ja es gibt das
teil element aber die gegenwärtige auch
gesellschaftlich zu händeln der
herausforderung geht aber nicht auf dann
geht es weiter hier mit der kohle muss
ich also zeitung ist die entschuldigung
sehe ich da auch ist sie müssen ja noch
die genau wie aber soll ich muss den
kollegen von der dpa enttäuschen ich
glaube nicht dass das ein problem ist
was man in einem satz erschöpfung
behandeln kann das ist irgendwie zu
komplex und das so knapp zu machen und
man müsste schon bei den empfehlungen
die angesprochen
wurden ja fragen an wen richten wir uns
eigentlich wen adressiert man wem möchte
man an dieser stelle jetzt eine
handreichung geben was für uns zentral
war war tatsächlich diese perspektive
dass wir aus bestimmten rechts
normativen grundvorstellungen
grundpfeilern unserer gesellschaft nicht
rauskommen oder diese grundpfeiler nicht
anrühren wollen und dass wir
andererseits sehen dass in einer
tragischen entscheidungssituation wie
der trias konstellation tatsächlich
diese rechtlichen parameter unter
umständen nicht ausreichen oder ist für
die handelnden unbefriedigend sein kann
sich allein daran zu orientieren und das
deshalb ist sinnvoller weise auch unter
gleichbehandlungsgesetz punkt
sinnvollerweise so sein kann dass man
sagt dass zusätzliche norm schichten
sich erschlossen werden die nicht
notwendigerweise nur konkretisieren
sondern die iren die unter umständen
sogar in einem gewissen widerstreit zu
den rechtlichen vorgaben stehen und die
insofern dazu führen dass wir zwar eine
einheitliche und vielleicht ethisch
moralisch akzeptabel aber deshalb nicht
notwendig rechtmäßige handlung haben das
ist ein widerspruch das ist eine
notlösung wenn sie so wollen aber das
ist der preis den wir zahlen müssen um
einerseits an unseren grund vorgaben
festhalten zu können und zwar nicht wir
als ethikrat sondern wir als
gesellschaft und andererseits die die
flexibilität zu haben aber auch die
einheitlichkeit zu haben um auf diese
tragische situation im einzelfall zu
reagieren also weniger als ein satz tut
mir leid aber ich glaube deutlich kürzer
geht es nicht jetzt habe ich eine frage
der kollegin
noch komplexer die für hoffenheim mit
den listen stehen nicht nur die personen
haben heute habe ich gerade optionen
ausreichende medizinische fragestellung
ist es sicherlich so dass da vieles noch
geklärt werden muss ob hinreichend
obduziert wird wie groß die gefahr bei
den obduktionen ist dazu müsste man
natürlich dann entsprechend die die
pathologen die pathologischen
fachgesellschaften fragen warum das in
der zeit nicht stattfindet kann ich
ihnen genau nicht sagen ich meine das rk
ii sagt das ist letztlich zu zu riskant
also müsste man gegebenenfalls da noch
mal nachfragen warum das sich dort ganz
anders darstellt als bei hiv oder
tuberkulose oder anderen erkrankungen wo
man das offensichtlich mit
entsprechender schutzkleidung ja
durchaus kann und gleichzeitig müssen
wir uns fragen was eigentlich die
erkenntnisse sind die wir aus diesen
obduktion gewinnen wollen ob die für uns
so relevant sind dass wir ein
möglicherweise auch nur kleines risiko
eingehen also in der tat das ist glaube
ich eine interessante offene frage was
heute angesprochen wurde heute morgen in
der faz ist auch wiederum ein offener
punkt zu sagen wir gehen wir eigentlich
mit der beatmung um was wann es eine
beatmung sinnvoll wie wird unter
umständen zu früh und zu intensiv
beatmet auch das ist etwas was
medizinisch diskutiert werden muss das
findet einen übergang in den normativen
bereich wenn sie sich dann die frage
stellen inwieweit kann ich das als
einzelner patient eigentlich
mitbestimmen und das leitet über zu der
frage inwieweit unsere
patientenverfügung unter umständen neu
gefasst und abgestimmt werden müssen auf
diese besondere situation muss ich den
menschen im land vielleicht besser
vermitteln dass dort spezifische risiken
gerade für die die älteren drohen wenn
sie langfristig beatmet werden und ihnen
auf diese weise die option oder
vielleicht sogar
einen hinweis geben dass sie das
vielleicht nicht wollen und umgekehrt
haben leute vielleicht eine klausel in
ihrer patientenverfügung dass sie eine
künstliche beatmung ablehnen aber in der
situation dass doch wollte
also das ist glaube ich auch etwas was
man durchaus überlegen muss die
handreichung in kurzer zeit in der tat
wir stehen alle unter zeitdruck und wir
alle würden uns natürlich wünschen dass
wir mehr möglichkeiten zur diskussion
hätten dass wir intensiver die dinge
bedenken können ich glaube dass wir als
gesellschaft als demokratisch verfasste
gesellschaft an der stelle auch gut
beraten uns klar zu machen dass es eben
nicht darum geht die eine richtige
lösung zu finden
auch jetzt bei den wegen aus der
gegebenen sind aktuellen situation
heraus wir können dinge auch tastend
machen wir können auch maßnahmen wieder
zurücknehmen das ist kein versagen von
politik wenn eine maßnahme sich als
nicht irgendwie erfolgreich erwiesen hat
dann das zu erkennen und zu sagen wir
nehmen sie zurück das gilt für den
einstieg in diese beschränkung maßnahmen
es geht aber auch und erst recht für den
ausstieg unter umständen versuchen wir
mal etwas vorsichtig und wenn es nicht
funktioniert dann lernen wir aus dieser
erfahrung also das wäre mein knapp 13
ganz kurze punkte ich von berg bei dem
letzten punkt an das greift auch nochmal
ihre frage von fohlen auf nämlich ob es
sozusagen eine katastrophe wäre wenn man
maßnahmen wieder einführt die man schon
zurückgenommen hätte es wird derzeit von
der politik quasi wie ein mantra vor
sich hergetragen dass das so sei dass
das die größte katastrophe sei wenn man
wieder eine maßnahme einführt die man
schon einmal gelockert hat auf der
anderen seite steht das sich durch
halten möglicherweise sehr stark
freiheit beschränken
massnahmen denn auch dass das war ja
quasi thesing hier auf dieser
veranstaltung erzeugt enorme
kollateralschäden und ich halte es auch
jetzt gegenüber der bevölkerung für
nicht völlig unmöglich zu kommunizieren
dass man geglaubt hat dass man lockern
kann aber das ist plötzlich eine solche
instanz von fallzahlen gibt die dazu
führt dass man doch noch einmal zurück
muss wenn man mich vor die alternative
stellt und sagt na ja du darfst jetzt
sozusagen vier jahre ins gefängnis
sondern sind wir konsequent oder nach
zwei jahren kommst du auf bewährung raus
und wenn es gut läuft kannst du bleiben
wenn es nicht gut läuft musste zurück
natürlich dass jetzt im klaren bin dann
würde ich mich persönlich für die zweite
alternative entscheiden also von daher
ich sehe natürlich was die politik damit
kommunizieren will will aber nur auf
appellieren daran dass es die andere
variante gibt mit kind auf die
medizinischen maßnahmen will ich zu den
dingen die er aufs berg gedacht hat ein
punkt auch noch ergänzen der zwischen
medizinischen notwendigkeiten um
kommunikation wiederum steht nämlich die
frage was ist eigentlich die
entscheidende größe an denen wir das
gegenwärtige problem in der korona krise
fest machen wir derzeit wird es in der
regel so kommuniziert dass gesagt wird
wir wollen nicht für eine bestimmte zeit
eine verdopplung der neue infektion aber
ist das eigentlich die entscheidende
größe oder ist nicht die entscheidende
größe das verhältnis zwischen den
kapazitäten die das medizinische system
zur verfügung stellen kann und den
schwer erkrankten also insbesondere
natürlich denjenigen die intensiv
wichtig werden das ist doch die grenze
die uns entweder gelassen oder nervös
werden lassen sollte und darüber noch
mehr zu kommunizieren
hielte ich für sinnvoll als uns
beispielsweise derzeit darin zu loben
dass wir in deutschland
so eine proportional geringe todesrate
haben dass ich immer bei einsender so
ein ranking der verschiedenen todesraten
und man denkt ja wir sind noch irgendwie
auf platz eins und das halte ich nicht
für relevant an der stelle
und ein letzter punkt ist nochmal mit
blick sie haben jetzt das medizinische
angesprochen
gesetzt den fall die krise dauert an
und auch diejenigen die im
gesundheitsbereich an der grenze der
erschöpfung arbeiten reichen nicht mehr
aus sollten wir auch gesellschaftlich
darüber nachdenken ob wir analog zu dem
wie wir es im katastrophenschutz er
jetzt hand haben menschen die
möglichkeit geben aus ihrem jetzigen
beruf daneben in denen dienst zu gehen
natürlich und insbesondere dann wenn sie
beispielsweise eine infektion schon
durchlaufen haben also auch das
verhältnis zwischen denjenigen die dann
irgendwann die infektion durchlaufen
haben und denjenigen die noch davor
stehen oder die gefährdet sind muss
glaube ich auch in der gesellschaft
nicht nur theoretisch sondern auch
praktisch viel stärker am debattiert
werden ich habe jetzt hier aus dem saal
noch frauen und frau wolff und noch eine
frage zur kommunikation der kollegin
vaters vom redaktions netzwerk
deutschland die darauf ab dass in den
vergangenen wochen die bundesländer zum
teil sehr unterschiedlich im umgang mit
krone agiert haben und sie fragt mit
blick auf die richtige kommunikation die
sie angesprochen haben wie wichtig ist
es dass in deutschland trotz
föderalismus einheitlich agiert wird
etwa mit an
eine exit strategie ich kann so ein
bisschen anschließend das was ich eben
gesagt habe gar nicht wichtig oder
jedenfalls nicht sehr wichtig warum soll
man nicht in den bundesländern
unterschiedlich reagieren
das ist doch gerade der sinn des
föderalismus dass man auf bestehende
unterschiede mit unterschiedlichen
regularien reagiert und es ist völlig
plausibel jedenfalls aus meiner sicht
prima fahrt hier irgendwie einleuchtend
dass wir im in ballungsgebieten
vielleicht andere regularien brauchen
als in großen flächenstaaten dass in
mecklenburg vorpommern wo die anzahl der
infizierten und entsprechend das risiko
relativ gering ist irgendwie anders
reagiere als in hamburg oder berlin und
jetzt gewissermaßen den mecklenburg
vorpommern war vorzuschreiben
ihr müsst alles genauso machen wie es in
berlin und hamburg erforderlich ist weil
die hamburger eben aus den skiferien
zurückgekommen sind sich danach auch
nicht vernünftig verhalten haben finde
ich nicht plausibel ich glaube der
föderalismus hat sich das möchte ich an
der betonen in dieser krise er bewahrt
und bewährt als dass er tatsächlich
irgendwie als als problem wahrgenommen
werden sollte und was die
kommunikationsstrategie angeht auch da
gilt unterschiedliche politiker in den
bundesländern pflegen unterschiedliche
kommunikationsstile pflegen natürlich
auch unterschiedliche regierungsziele
und preschen vielleicht mal mehr mal
weniger vor
auch das ist in einem demokratisch
verfassten gemeinwesen gewollt in
unserem föderalen system ist das auch
ein element des wettbewerbs das
ermöglicht es uns jedenfalls im klein
und dass man das so als böses experiment
irgendwie dann gleich wie versteht auch
dinge auszuprobieren also ich wäre da
ganz ganz hoffnungsfroh dass insoweit
wir auch eine chance haben dinge
auszuprobieren nicht ergänzend dazu ein
[Musik]
wettbewerb um die möglichst angemessenen
und dass er bei uns eben
verhältnismäßige maßnahmen auch zwischen
den medizinischen notwendigen und dann
möglichen öffnungs perspektiven kann und
soll es geben
persönlich begrüße ich dass es mehr und
mehr dann doch auch zu konsensualen
absprachen gekommen ist
am zwischen landesregierungen und die
aufgabe das was steffen augsburg gerade
formuliert hat nämlich dass einzelne
bundesländer einzelne regionen spezifika
haben aber miteinander abzusprechen um
zu versuchen gemeinsame kriterien zu
identifizieren die dann in
unterschiedlichen regionen
unterschiedlich umgesetzt werden können
das ist ja genau der sinn solcher
unterschiedlicher kulturen und regionen
das wäre schon etwas was sicherlich auch
für eine mediale öffentlichkeit die eben
doch sehr häufig neben der lokalen ebene
auch die bundesebene im blick hat schon
etwas um das man sich dann auch bemühen
kann dann geht es mit frau braun weiter
also wir haben eine reaktion
wenn sie jetzt die persönliche reaktion
meinen erhalten darüber hinaus gibt es
auch auf den unterschiedlichen ebenen
sowohl im parlament als auch im bereich
der regierung immer wieder bilaterale
gespräche dass das eine gesagt dass
andere es gibt auch vom ethikrat ein
gewisses maß an ernster gelassenheit
dass wir nicht wie andere im politischen
berlin und da halte ich das für völlig
legitim sozusagen gänzlich darauf
angewiesen sind dass wir sofort
sozusagen öffentlich applaus oder nicht
er applaus bekommen das ist genau der
sinn einer solchen institution wie des
ethikrates dass er selber in einer
freiheit die eben die bundesrepublik
deutschen auf gesetzlicher ebene diesen
institutionen bietet agieren können und
auf die art und weise doch so meine
erfahrung in den letzten vier jahren und
das ist ja heute auch für mich der
letzte öffentliche auftritt als
vorsitzender des deutschen ethikrates
doch viele möglichkeiten gezeigt hat wie
man auf die eine oder andere weise
hiermit im gespräch sein kann und das
finde ich sage es einmal mit einem
ehemaligen kollegen der gesagt hat wenn
sie ethikrat ich gäbe müsste man ihn
erfinden und das kann ich aus acht
jahren dankbar heraus jedenfalls zu
sagen und zur flankierung von dem was
sie gerade gesagt haben kann ich noch
sagen dass das sie auf unseren unseren
wunsch den wunsch der
bundespressekonferenz heute hier sind
dass wir sie ein
dann haben wir sind froh sind dass sie
uns heute zur verfügung stehen so dass
unsere initiative frau
das war soweit beantwortet ich wollte
ich damit nicht in so nem ihren
[Musik]
ich bin natürlich hier in den
österreichischen maßnahmen jetzt nicht
so vertraut wie ich das glaube ich mit
dem was in deutschland vonstattengeht
bin aber insgesamt diese mischung
zwischen auf der einen seite konsequente
perspektive maßnahmen durchzuführen
auch welche bei denen wir derzeit ja sie
also immer noch räumen
doch ganz erheblich kontroverse debatte
unter den virologen beispielsweise haben
ob sie sinnvoll sind nämlich die frage
über mal über masken in der
öffentlichkeit zu tragen ob das sinnvoll
ist oder nicht und dann gleichzeitig
sachorientiert sache orientiert und mit
blick auf die möglichen nebenfolgen zeit
perspektiven anzugehen halte ich im
prinzip für ein sinnvolles vorgehen so
weit ich es aber aus österreich
mitbekommen habe ist das ja auch nicht
alles auch das halte ich nicht für
schönen völlig freiwillig passiert
sondern es hat eben auch in der
österreichischen öffentlichkeit eine
debatte über solche öffnungs
perspektiven über lockerungen gegeben so
dass bundeskanzler kurz da auch in
gewisser weise reagiert hat oder etwas
vielleicht schöner formuliert sich rest
von sieff gezeigt hat und gezeigt hat
wie er eben auf diese bedürfnisse in der
öffentlichkeit eingehend ohne den
konsequenten gesundheitsschutz dadurch
zu vernachlässigen habe ich irgendwelche
fragen übersehen das scheint mir mich
der fall zu sein und auch nicht von den
kollegen draußen dann danke ich sehr
herzlich für ihre zeit dass wir uns so
lange zur verfügung gestanden haben so
viele schwierige antworten auf
schwierige fragen gegeben haben
und unsere tür steht in jederzeit offen
wir danken frau gefasst